when you do a show like numbers I I I
remember watching
numbers and I remember
thinking I could never do this I could
never play this part I could never I the
words he's saying the amount of dialogue
he has you're doing how many episodes a
year
22 yeah how much dialogue did you have
per episode on
average uh a lot but you know
um I I I I it was it was it was the job
you know that was job it was the job I
mean but like listen to me are you are
you a you have photographic uh memory no
you
don't I maybe on some level I do how how
long does it take you to learn your
lines so for numbers what happened was
we started doing the show and uh you
know i' go home I'd learn the night
before wake up the next morning and it
was such complicated jargon what I was
speaking that I'd forget it so I'd be in
the shower going holy crap I stayed up
for three hours straight working on
these lines and I can't remember them
and there were days on set where I had
like many crises you know in the
beginning and two things had to happen
one I had to stop being afraid of not
knowing the lines my fear of not getting
them you you know this with with heavy
with heavy dialogue the more afraid you
are of not knowing it the less chance
you're going to have to know it like you
you've got to not be afraid and I was
really afraid so I had to drop that how
do you drop that how do you just drop
that
[Music]
um I I came up with a plan but it it
wasn't a plan that everybody liked I
will say that I will say that what was
the
plan okay so I was like I went to the
producers and I said the the The Genius
of the character is catching up with the
capabilities of the
actor and I was like and I don't want
you guys to like rewrite anything
because I'm stupid you know I don't want
you to have to do that um one of the
things I asked them to do was they would
like give me like a whole long speech
and in the speech I'd have the same
complicated word eight times within that
speech so let's say the word is Al
algorithm okay I'd have to say algorithm
eight times within that speech and the
problem the way the my brain works at
least is like I get to the third
algorithm and think it was the sixth you
know what I mean and skip over a bunch
of dialogue as a result I'd [__] up
right so I asked them I said if there's
any way to not do that to like if you
know to reward it yeah get your get your
thesaurus out and like what's another
word for algorithm like call it a
formula call it whatever you know and
they did that was really that was the
only ask I had for them that's not big
of an ask no I would have said Q cards
earwig that's all I asked well so then
what I did I said and here's the deal
I'm gonna come in not knowing him and
they were like what and I was like I'm
gonna come in not knowing my lines and
they were not happy with that and I said
here's what going to happen I'm going to
come in I'm going to not know them at
all I'm then going to spend the 20
minutes that it takes for you to set up
the first shot after
rehearsal with our script
supervisor and if she can't do it we got
to get somebody who can anyone who's
willing to on set will do it with me and
I'm gonna cram them I'm just G to cram
the [__] out of them pressure's on I got
150 people waiting on me to learn these
lines that's how I'm going to learn
these
F and and so that's how we did it for
six years and um and you know first
takes sucked you know it cost a couple
takes you know I would [__] up but then
by the third take I get it and what was
great about it was you're watching me
kind of get it as I'm getting as I'm
performing and it looks like to the
audience the audience sees a
mathematician coming up with the ideas
as he said as you're thinking
remembering his lines so it looks
spontaneous and so it started to work
and I started to make sure that I you
know first takes were better second
takes and we did we moved so fast in
that show we ended up doing 10hour days
most of the time um nine pages in 10
hours like we rock rock that show and so
it got easier for me got easier for
everybody and then no one cared
everybody was like fine this is the way
we're doing it this is the way could you
do it now if Christopher Nolan said I
just wrote a paragraph for you can you
do it no way see on numbers
unfortunately or fortunately numbers
became you do 22 Episodes a year it
becomes monotonous it becomes a job um
I'm not saying that there you don't keep
the work honest or that there isn't
passion behind it but at a certain point
you just go wow I got to get the job
done so I may not be um
cons as concerned with how I perform
this scene as I am with getting the
lines right right